The rising tensions between Russia and the U.S....
…have sparked major questions about the future of the International Space Station.
Moscow now says it intends to withdraw from the project after 2024.
NASA and other international partners want to keep the station in orbit until 2030,...
…but without the Russians, that may not be possible.
Mark Strassman is outside the Johnson Space Center in Houston.
Mark, good morning.
Hey Jerica, good morning to you.
No question, NASA caught off guard by this announcement from Moscow...
…came without warning.
It has also come, still without official confirmation, to the U.S. space agency.
It is really odd behavior...
…given the fact that the Russians have been the U.S.'s major space partner...
…internationally for the last quarter century.
Already orbiting on borrowed time,...
...the ISS could have its longevity shortened further by this announcement from Moscow.
Yuri Borisov, Russia's new space director, tells President Vladimir Putin, quote,...
"The decision to leave the station after 2024 has been made,...
...so Russia can begin building its own space station".
Putin's response, "Good."
Do you want the relationship to end?
No, absolutely not.
Robyn Gatens, NASA's ISS director, taken by surprise at a conference.
We haven't received any official word from the, from the partner...
...as to the news today,...
…and so we'll be talking more about their plan going forward.